let me just put this out here because i
want to get into amazon the business i
think that's like the most fascinating
part
but
having known
jeff not personally but you know been in
the same room with him and having mutual
friends and this kind of thing
um
did he have some crazy midlife crisis is
that what's going on the last five years
when
you know he got divorced
um he starts dating i mean he
essentially
steals his friend's wife uh i think is
the only way to say it right and he
pretty much goes out there
unabashedly dating another guy's wife
and i don't want to make the salacious
but
on top of that then quits his job
starts flying helicopters he looks like
he's on performance
drugs or he's working out like eight
times a day i mean he's just colossal
like you've seen the memes
uh and um you know the hollywood thing
seems to be on track as a business i
don't think that was the midlife crisis
but certainly
quitting and then saying i'm gonna go do
what elon does and make rocket ships uh
is
was quite a turn of events was it not
it was it's remarkable and jason you'll
appreciate that i started working on
this book in 2018 so i didn't anticipate
any of this that that the my my team
little business book would take a left
turn into you know the national enquirer
dick pics and um a salacious hollywood
scandal like that i did not anticipate
that but
you know like i'll say a couple things
one
you know
first of all we can't yeah i was very
wary of assuming that we had all the
facts that we could know all the facts
people's private lives or the details of
a marriage
you know are are somewhat unknowable
they're very private people i ultimately
don't know the extent to which you know
his first marriage was over before it
became public knowledge um at the very
least he made there was some
questionable judgment and as you say
being so open about the relationship at
a time when public interest in him
because he was the wealthiest person in
the world and the ceo of amazon was so
high like there was clearly an error in
judgment uh and then i tell the whole
story about how he kind of in some ways
weaponized his ownership of the
washington post to attack the national
enquirer and did so very successfully um
you know is it a midlife crisis i mean i
think
my my sense is that you know
he as he got wealthier as he became more
of a member of elite society he
determined that he enjoyed it you know
and he enjoyed the trappings of of the
of the the super yacht st bart's
lifestyle going to the conferences and i
know for a fact that mackenzie uh now
you know now uh formerly mackenzie bezos
did not enjoy that lifestyle she's very
private right and and so you can kind of
see their stars moving in opposite
directions and she's obviously you know
created quite a mistake for herself now
as a as a philanthropist but um yeah it
seems to me that like i don't know if it
was a midlife crisis as much as it was
him wanting to really continue
living a life of public adventure
um you know or or and enjoying his
wealth um the one thing the one quick
other thing i'd say is you know he had
the space vision before elon blue origin
you know precedes spacex but he executed
it horribly and i have a chapter on this
in in my book and you know elon runs
spacex bezos has always administered to
it from a distance and and sewed all
kind of dysfunction because of that and
so now we see him trying to catch up
putting himself at risk to take that
flight filing lawsuits against spacex
it's going to be interesting drama to
watch bezos doesn't like to come in
second on anything and with space i he's
he's maybe third or fourth at this point
yeah i mean in in fairness to e he was
into rockets in college too but i think
you're right maybe blue origin
might have technically incorporated
first right it was all that yeah like 2
two thousand one time and they and they
would go to lunch and breakfast and eli
talked to elon for the book and he was
he was telling jeff he was pursuing the
wrong rocket architecture and and jeff
wouldn't listen and then of course you
know he made some mistakes yeah it it's
super weird i have to say watching jeff
um who i think is just a tremendous
entrepreneur be so insecure about this
rocket stuff i don't know if you saw
that they tweeted at branson that he
didn't actually go to the right level of
space by the definition that 60 of
people consider did you see those crazy
infographics
and then he criticizes elon and then
he's trying to like sue to catch up what
is going who's advising him or does he
not have
people around him who tell him what a
bad look it is because he looks
i mean he's jeff bezos i mean we all
respect him he's done such amazing
things in the world
and then to be like
you know richard branson's an old guy he
went to space you know it's like it
could have all been like a jovial fun
space race of the summer and then bezos
made it so petty and like you didn't go
high enough i went higher than you it's
just it was kind of sad when you started
did you think that's just sad
yes um obviously it is and he hasn't he
hasn't done himself many favors um at
the van horne press conference
um
you know announcing the philanthropic
gift to
you know to to two individuals as he's
talking about the trip wearing a cowboy
hat with the spacesuit um the jubilation
after you know a 10-minute ride yeah it
it all struck me as somewhat bizarre um
you know does he have people around him
that might be counseling otherwise i
mean when you when you achieve the lo
well you jason you've seen this probably
again you achieved that level of success
and
you know you tend to probably think that
you know best so i don't know if he's is
he is he not listening to folks um or uh
is the company doing yeah i tend to
think that it's it probably does come
from him
yeah
he
you cannot
pick a fight as a corporation without
the founder ceo's approval to start a
fight right
you would be fired the next day no pr
marketing person's like i've got an idea
let's you know denigrate like richard
branson's like life dream and and in
order to pump up jeff it's like no jeff
told him like hey we should make an
infographic that does exactly this
right um and he said at the press
conference he said i'd like to thank
employees and customers were paying for
all this it was
absolutely crazy yeah yeah
have you ever felt anxious in a really
expensive suit i know i have you put it
on your shelf you can have all that
anxiety you're not gonna wanna wear it i
have an amazing tip for you it's called
indochino i have been getting my suits
at indochino and they are gorgeous you
go to the store they measure you and
then they talk to you about what you
like all the different aspects of the
suit the fabric the way the pockets work
the lapels they'll even put a monogram
in there or
really gorgeous what they would call
like a statement lining a lining that
when you turn your jacket inside out and
lay it on the chair next to you people
go wow that's a gorgeous suit where did
you get it from and i tell people i got
it from indochina they say it fits
perfect it looks great on you and that's
the thing about suits when they are
custom made and they fit you perfect
you'll look like a million bucks
indochino suits start at just
399. the best part is that once you have
all of that sizing information they can
just ship you another suit additionally
if you want to alter it a little bit you
think maybe i could take this in maybe i
take that out over here
change the length because sometimes you
know maybe you want to do that after you
get it they'll give you a 75 credit to
go to a local tailor and do that it is a
no-brainer indochino is now open and
select nordstrom stores to find the
nearest location go to indochino.com
i-n-d-o-c-h-i-n-o dot com
plus right now you're gonna get 50 off
any purchase of 3.99 or more
just by using the code twist twist at
checkout